Capitalism is based on a set of rational
choice theory.
Rational choice theory is I'm mathematic
formulation that has demonstrably
benefits in terms of avoiding,
um,
simple errors in judgment and decision
making.
Um,
it's undergoing some revision because
some of the biases and errors that we
make,
uh,
can be understood and improve those
formulas.
But there are two assumptions underlying
rational choice that are assumptions.
They're not part of the mathematics,
they're assumptions.
One is,
uh,
because short term interests and the
other is selfish interests.
You do what's good for you.
And it's as society becomes more
complex,
as scientific inquiry becomes more
has daily living,
he comes more complex,
um,
coordinating our efforts together
working so that we can trust one
another.
Uh,
specialized,
I can count on you to do a,
and I'll do b and together a and b are
more than the sum of the parts.
Um,
that kind of problem solving which
suggest selfish interests is an
assumption that may have outlived its
usefulness that it's not about being
pure alteras.
Uh,
it's about coming up with something
where you relate to other people in a
fashion where everybody benefits more,
where the sum is greater than the total
is greater than the sum of the parts.
And that's,
uh,
that's just an assumption.
If we put that assumption in the
rational choice theory,
all of a sudden capitalism looks a
little bit different.
We look for sustainability,
we look for things that are good for the
community as well as for the company.
Um,
and you see such efforts,
uh,
southwest airline is just one airline
that was built,
uh,
caring as much about their employees as
the customers.
And,
uh,
you know,
southwest has been,
uh,
something of a business success stories.
Some of the Asian companies are
similarly constructed around a concern
for the community and the employees,
not just the stockholders.
And that is again,
they want to serve stockholders,
but they want to serve beyond
stockholders and a,
those are again,
some of the real success stories.
So I think we're seeing precedents set
and,
and it can,
it's not a denial of rational choice
theory.
It's really just a questioning of one of
the assumptions underlying it.
And I think there's,
there's good reason to pursue what
might,
what might be done with capitalism with
that assumption.
A change.
CHICAGO,
I've worked with
some economists sentence.
One of the things that we look at are
the errors.
People making judgment.
Um,
oh,
35 years ago,
economists never assume did rational
choice that people were rational.
They assume that irrationality was so
irrational,
is to be random.
And economics isn't about predicting an
individual behavior.
That's the domain of psychology.
Economics is about predicting aggregate
behavior.
Well,
if I have complete irrationality,
that's random,
that's just like noise and I average
over many such random noise.
That sums does zero.
So you're left with just rationality.
Uh,
I think what the last 30 years of
research and particularly current
research and behavioral economics and in
neuroeconomics this showing us that the
irrationality of systematic,
it's not always random.
There were systematic biases that we
introduced.
One of the biases that that people show
is if they want to not come to be true,
they overestimate the odds versus if
they don't want the outcome to be true.
And so that's it's bias that once you
realize you can tweak the mathematics
just so that it's more [inaudible]
presented about how humans actually
think can be age.
I think our research,
Sean,
what's fundamentally all about
human nature has implications for how we
live our lives now.
Businesses conduct research.
Um,
there is a sense in which bringing these
teams together with different expertise
gives you the opportunity to attack
problems,
come up with more creative solutions
than not because of the complexity you
need those different levels of
expertise,
but it bringing people together isn't
sufficient.
Being,
overcoming loneliness isn't about just
connecting with another person.
It's connecting at a deep level.
That's reinforcing for both individuals.
Businesses if they understand that
principle can understand that bringing
experts together isn't sufficient.
It's bringing the experts together and
allowing them or promoting their
connection so that it's beyond what
would you normally would get.
So,
just to give you an example in the
research domain,
uh,
I've been a member of research teams
where we would fly into a vicinity.
We meet,
meet,
meet.
Once I flew to Bergen,
Norway,
which was a long flight.
We met in some hotel meeting room for
two days and then flew home.
I have no idea what Norway looked like.
It was one of the most miserable
meetings.
I was just jet lag.
That's all it was.
And I'm sure we got something from the
meeting,
but not very much.
Uh,
there are other meetings.
I,
I run a large interdisciplinary team of
wonderful,
wonderful colleagues.
The research in the book is really
representing the work of many different
scientific disciplines and expertise.
Um,
and when we,
when we come together to meet,
we meet off campus first of all and we
meet off campus because when we're on
campus,
we're busy.
I mean,
we all have things going on and we,
it's hard to disconnect our minds from
our students and our colleagues and
other demands when we go off campus.
We also bring family with us and we have
meetings only for about six hours a day
and we have formal gatherings as a
group.
We eat together,
we break bread together,
we'd go on outings together,
we go for walks together in various sub
pairings.
And what that allows you to do is rather
than saying this is what I know and
promoting,
that you start to like these people,
you start to understand and want to want
to understand more about their
perspective.
And so rather than relying just on what
we all already agree so we can get outta
here,
you say,
well,
okay,
that's what we all think,
but that's the common knowledge and we
all had that's not actually taking
advantage of the expertise that unique.
And really the reason we're all here is
because of the unique knowledge,
not the common knowledge.
That takes longer and that unique
knowledge starts to come out on these
walks and it starts to come out in the
meetings after you've done those walks
because it's not about coming to a quick
solution.
It's about coming to a playful that
said,
well tell me what you might know and why
would you think that.
I mean,
and I'm not attacking you in that.
I'm actually curious in that.
So all of a sudden the language
differences and the disciplinary
differences are easier to bridge.
I think that in that lesson in science,
there's a lesson for businesses as well
to bring together expertise and that
expertise may be different,
uh,
parts of the product line or it may be
labor versus management,
different interests,
expertise.
How does one transcend and really do
something that's better for everybody in
the longterm?
Because that's,
that's what I think the secret of our,
our species,
we're very good at coming up with those
new kind of social kind of construct.
If you look at the emperor penguin,
they require huddles to get through the
winter there.
I think they get together in this
collective and without that collective,
none of them would survive.
Right?
That's the vehicle for genetic
transmission is this group that's bigger
than the individual.
That's the only collective unit.
Humans have many such collectors and we
can create them and recreate them on a
moment by moment basis.
And so the real talent and capacity
comes from how do we configure those so
that they're productive.
Yeah.